hello and welcome the topic for today is
newton's method
one of the most important methods in
optimization
before we jump in and discuss what
newton's method is all about
let me take a moment and set this stage
for the rest of this lecture
today we will focus exclusively on
unconstrained optimization
what that means is that we are given a
multivariate
scalar valued function f or said
differently
we have a function in n variables that
takes real values
and we want to minimize this function
globally meaning that we want to find
the point
x of r n where f takes the smallest
possible value
one thing you can do of course is simply
plot a graph of the function
an eyeball where the minimizer is it
seems pretty easy right
well there are two problems with this
approach
first you can only get so much precision
out of a plot like this one
and the second and most important
problem is that
we cannot really plot functions that
depend on more than two variables
in some applications for example in
machine learning robotics
the functions we are interested in
minimizing depend on tens
thousands sometimes even millions of
variables
you can't really plot a function of a
million variables so what can we do in
that case
some of the most useful and most used
algorithms belong to the family of
iterative
optimization algorithms and newton
method
as we will see belongs to this family
so the way this works is as follows you
start with some initial guess x0
usually the closer this initial guess is
to the true minimizer
the better since the true minimizer is
unknown
in practice we just draw this initial
condition
from some random distribution
next we pick a direction ie a vector
d0 and we follow it to obtain x1
we can compute f of x1 to track how much
progress we have made
hopefully f of x1 is smaller than f of
x0
meaning that we have descended the
valley that the graph of the function
f traces in space for this reason
this direction is usually called a
descent direction
this family of algorithms is called
iterative because this process repeats
again and again
at iteration k i am at some point x k
i pick a vector d k i follow it
i reach x k plus 1 and i can of course
evaluate
f at x k and x k plus 1 to see how much
progress i have made
the crucial question here of course is
that
when i am at the point xk how can i pick
the direction decay
this is a crucial question because the
way you answer this question
determines which algorithm you're using
so let's take a moment
to think about what information we can
use to pick
a good descent direction
when you think about it we need to
understand how the function varies
in a neighborhood of x k this is where
multivariate calculus comes in really
handy
the gradient of a function for example
tells us the direction of
biggest increase of this function so
it is no surprise that there is an
algorithm called gradient descent
that picks minus the gradient as a
descent direction
similarly higher order derivatives can
also be useful
the hessian for example contains useful
information about the curvature
of the function if this seems a little
too abstract at this point
let me be more concrete let's consider
the following univariate function
f this is simply a polynomial of degree
4
and while we will be working here with
one variable for simplicity
everything we will do will generalize to
higher dimensions
let's start by plotting this function to
see what it looks like
the minimizer of this function is
somewhere here let's call it
x star but let's pretend for the moment
that we do not know where this minimizer
is
instead let's try to use some kind of
iterative algorithm
where i am at some iteration k and i
want to design the next descent
direction
i have mentioned that the gradient can
be useful for that and in one dimension
the gradient is nothing but the
derivative and the derivative is a limit
of this ratio in the right when x tends
towards
x k this ratio can be interpreted as the
rate of change of the function
f around the point x k if
we rearrange the terms a little bit we
see that the derivative
is the slope of the tangent line to the
graph of f
at x k this means that if we really zoom
in
around x k f here in blue and its linear
approximation
represented by a yellow line are pretty
much indistinguishable
so here is an idea why not minimize the
yellow function instead
minimizing a linear function is the
easiest thing in the world
if the slope is positive we have to go
to the left
as much as possible and if the slope is
negative
like here you have to go to the right as
much as possible
in both cases what we're doing is
subtracting a positive multiple of the
slope
or the derivative from our current
iterate
alpha here is called the step size
a linear function is typically unbounded
so
you might think that alpha should be as
large as possible
but remember we want to minimize f
not its linear approximation and far
away from xk
the blue and yellow functions might
behave in completely
different ways if we take alpha to be
too large we might overshoot and miss
the minimizer
and if we take alpha to be too small
then we might take a lot more iterations
than is actually needed trying to tune
this alpha in an optimal way
is what leads us to newton's method
newton's method
is based on the observation that using
the second derivative
in addition to the first derivative can
be helpful
if you remember taylor series from your
calculus class
we can refine this approximation here by
including
the second derivative of f to get an
even better
approximation the resulting function is
no longer linear
but quadratic and now the idea is the
same
instead of minimizing the blue function
f let's minimize this red function
this red quadratic function and let's
pick the minimizer of the quadratic
function
as our next iterate for ease of
exposition here
i am skipping over some technical
details related to the existence and
uniqueness of such a minimizer
anyway with a little bit of algebra you
realize
that this is exactly the same thing as
taking alpha to be
one over the second derivative of f at
the point x k
and this is exactly what newton's method
is all about
note that we do not need to pick the
step size alpha manually anymore
when you stare at this expression and
figure out all the details
you realize that it generalizes to the
case of
multivariate functions in exactly the
way you would expect it to
you simply replace the first derivative
with the gradient
and you replace one over the second
derivative
by the inverse of the hessian which is a
matrix
if you have seen newton's method before
it might have looked a little different
usually when newton's method is
presented it is about
finding a solution to an equation g of x
equals zero
what we have seen today is how to find
an x that
minimizes a function f of x
as it turns out these two operations are
related
when you minimize a function what you
are looking for are critical points
of that function and a critical point is
where the derivative
equals zero so in order to solve an
equation g of x equals zero
you can try to look for a minimizer of
the integral of g
which leads to the more familiar formula
that you see over here
let us now discuss some good and bad
things about newton's method
arguably the biggest pro of newton's
method
is its fast convergence more precisely
when you get close to the minimizer
newton's method has quadratic
conversions
at a high level what this means is that
at every iteration
we double the number of exact digits in
our approximation
for instance take the equation x cubed
minus
three times x equals zero square root of
three
or one point seven three two zero etc is
one of the solutions
if we were to solve this equation with
newton's method
starting at the point x zero equals two
then
in the first iteration we would have two
significant digits at the second
iteration we would have three
at the third we would have 6 then 12
then 23 etc
this lecture would not be complete
without mentioning
some bad properties of newton's method
let me mention an important fact before
that newton's method
can be directly applied to find complex
zeros
not just real zeros for example
we could use it to solve this equation
which has three complex roots which are
the
cube roots of unity
if i use newton's method to solve this
equation
which zero am i going to convert to well
that will depend on how i pick the
initial point
x0 here let me color each point of the
plane
with a different color depending on
which zero i convert
to if i start from there when i do that
i get this beautiful fractal-like
picture
and as you can see you can have many
points that are
arbitrarily close to each other that
have different colors
meaning that newton's method would
behave very differently
the sensitivity to the initial point can
be problematic at times
another drawback of newton's method is
its scalability
if you have a function of n variables
you would need
n square memory units just to store the
hessian
and to compute the inverse of this
session as is needed by newton's method
you would need about n cubed operations
this might be fine if you have 10
variables but
if you have let's say ten thousand
variables
it quickly becomes infeasible i should
mention here that
there are some variants of newton's
method usually called
quasi-newton methods that somehow avoid
computing the hessian and its inverse
but that's a topic for another day
thank you very much for listening and
see you next time